Don't forget that membership is the number
one way the David Pakman show is funded.
Grab a membership and get all of the associated
benefits, including the daily bonus show,
world famous by signing up at join Pacman
dot com.
Let's go to let's go to the phones at six
one seven eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Starting today with our caller from the nine
eight zero area code.
Caller from nine eight zero.
What's your name and where are you calling
from today?
Paula.
Yes, that's you.
Sweet.
Hi, my name is Stan.
I'm calling from North Carolina.
What's going on?
Oh, so I just have one time and one long question
questioned.
So.
I know.
I've noticed that you do either.
Right.
Like last independence voices on you to have,
like, made this claim about like vote out
Donald Trump.
Yes, fine.
And then we'll and then we'll push.
Biden left or we'll hold them accountable.
And like, I just don't get that.
I kind of see that as basically a big as a
big of a lie as like, oh, Biden is going to
be the next FDR.
FDR or whatever, just because, like, what
level of protest scene or organizing is going
to push.
Biden laughs that 200 dead Americans have
a question where there are millions of unemployed
Americans who have also lost their health
care.
Has a person left that like months of protesting
against police brutality?
Has it pushed him less?
And we've still got the cop or V.P..
Well, hold on a second, but let's examine
that if we can.
If you compare Joe Biden today to Joe Biden,
even five years ago, never mind ten or fifteen
or 47, as Donald Trump likes to do, the move
to the left has been dramatic.
Has it not?
I mean, you look at Biden's position today
on health care, which includes, you know,
again, it's not single payer, but it's public
option open to lowering the Medicare age by
five or 10 years, which would give millions
of people access subsidizing to a higher level
of income.
Right.
All these we're talking about tens of millions
of more people getting health care.
You look at cannabis just coming out and saying
full federal decriminalization of cannabis
like he's already moved to the left.
And I think what we mean when we say we continue
to push is when we look at the House and Senate,
the more left those legislative bodies go,
the more progressive will be the bills that
get put on President Joe Biden's desk.
It all seems coherent to me.
Well, I still don't quite see it just as sorry.
You don't see it.
OK.
But you said it was one of the biggest lies.
You've heard that.
Who's lying?
Who are the people lying?
I like you, but it may not happen and you
may not be confident in it.
But I don't know that it's a big lie.
So I would say like you, or perhaps like maybe
Jameson, the Young Turks or David Dole from
Russia National, like a few cities, will say
person by the left.
I'm just curious, what exactly does that look
like?
Because like millions of people lost their
health insurance.
Two hundred thousand dead Americans.
Violence still won't endorse a full like Medicare
for all universal health care plan.
And even then, like on the public option,
I'm pretty sure there's like a political article
that says that they might not even put up
a public option just to get like some brownie
points for working with Republicans.
Okay, well, that's that's speculative.
And we have to see if that happens.
But I just I think I just disagree with with
the framing.
I mean, it's you know, we have to understand
what what do we have control over and what
do we not have control over?
Different people had different preferences
in the primary.
Biden's the nominee.
Now, the options we now now that's beyond
our control.
Now, the option is who's President Trump or
Biden?
We can vote.
If Biden is president, then what can we control?
We can't go back and make Bernie the president.
So all we can do is lobby and elect the most
progressive possible Senate and House.
Like, we just we have to focus on what we
can do.
And I just don't see sort of the point of
speculating that people are lying about pushing
Biden left.
It's what can we do?
And that is actually something that is a coherent,
cohesive strategy if Joe Biden becomes president.
No.
So what, like people will push on?
Isn't that right?
The lie is that people will want to push and
laugh.
OK.
It the idea of like.
Him being possible?
Well, to the last but the last 10 years are
evidence.
Look at Biden's part.
Look at Biden's policy on health care, economics
and energy today and look at what he was part
of in terms of policy during the Obama administration.
I mean, even in the last four years, Joe Biden
has been pulled significantly to the left.
But even Hillary Clinton suggests an even
lower age for Medicare, for Medicare.
That may be, but you look at the sum total.
I mean, look at the look at the economic policy
that Joe Biden is proposing.
Look at uncapping Social Security tax.
Doing away with a lower rate for capital gains.
An alternative, a minimum tax for corporations
like these.
These are big things that Hillary Clinton,
from what I recall, was not even talking about
in 2016.
Listen, I gotta run because I've got a lot
of people holding, but I think I would I would
maybe rethink some of your ideas and see if
they're really passing the sniff test.
Oh, sir.
All right, my friend.
Thank you so much, appreciate the call.